and I think for a startup is basically
moving from one stage like a startup is
a very interesting experience because
like your pains are different like you
always have pain uh you always have like
a suffering but like the pain is
different in every stage so now it's
basically scaling and building like a
larger organization basically building a
machine process system Etc
nurse just sit back relax and learn from
the leaders of today it's a journey each
one is different unique inspiring let's
get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
Omer glass welcome to 20 minute leaders
all the way from the growth space
offices how you doing
I'm good thank you Michael thank you
very very much for being with me oh man
I'm really excited to talk to you about
uh really at the end it's people people
and their professional beings and the
learning team building kpis how the
independent person impacts an
organization and this sort of this
relationship building that is really
interesting and so
um running a very interesting company
growth space I'm excited to dive into
this world with you so thank you very
much for being with me Oman
thank you so much excited
hey how did you get into the world of
Professional Building
Talent organizational productivity how
did you get into these worlds
so I I think it's
like personal hobby or passion of mine
one of the best things we can do as
humans is to grow eventually so I think
for me every choice I made personally in
my adult life or even as a kid was a
type 2 how much will it grow eventually
so my first like
when I went to my Army service I wanted
to grow like there in specific elements
when I chose my first job after
University I basically I didn't care how
much you were going to pay me I cared
about like what are they going to teach
me so I think it was the passion of mine
and I think it's one of the best things
we do as humans eventually because why
are we here right you do not want to
stay stagnant you want to grow and
become better in all aspects of life
right in relationships and with your
family and with the work and with
intellect and whatever your interests
are so we're a species that grows
eventually
it grows yes definitely a new Ray and I
I already like some of the philosophical
questions but we're not going to get
into some of those today but
um when we're looking at growth pain to
me the landscape of the challenges
around growth because what you're
talking about while I believe every
person listening here will agree it's
it's another thing that we can all agree
on is that it's very much not a trivial
um not a trivial task for any of us
right for us amongst ourselves for us as
CEOs for employees
what is the challenge behind growth
so the basic challenge is behind behind
growth is like that we're doing things
we're stretching ourselves right a lot
of us are working in startups so like
you're expected to grow with 2x 3x 4X
like in their earlier stages so when
you're trying to eventually grow
companies and develop companies it means
that you will have less stretch kpis
right and the stretch deliveries because
if you're doing something that's very
easy for you you do not have to grow you
can just lean back do your work nine to
five drop the pan and go home I think
most of us in the current ERA are in the
professional aspect were basically
required to grow as a feature of the
system right it's a bag of feature so I
think it's it's a feature that companies
need to grow which means they're like
the companies are basically the sums of
their people so all people and need to
grow and I think the interesting thing
about growth it's it's not identical for
two like specific people you need to ask
yourself like how can we grow them
systematically as a company and and how
can we tailor the right growth for each
individual because they think of like
five of your managers one will need to
focus on their functional expertise so I
want you to improve your Sales
Management tactics one would like to
focus on their managerial skills one is
to improve their productivity like how
they organize their time or even a
communication skills how do you
communicate upwards right so growth has
a lot of different and like Arenas
eventually so we would like to find the
right solution for each member in each
company
okay
key incites around you know how to
tailor that growth to fine-tune that
growth whether it be you know
individually or at scale what were some
of the key insights you've had along the
way with growth space that allowed you
to be successful thus far
so I think the key insight about growth
is that you first need to understand
what type like what is the outcome what
is the outcome in the organizational
level and what is the outcome in the
individual level so first let's talk
like a bit about what grocery does in
order to dive into like how we're doing
that so just in high high level World
space helps companies to manage their
human to human development why is that
because in like learning you can learn
things from YouTube or from online
courses but usually the impact happens
when people help other people grow with
all the AI and chat jpt if you want to
grow as humans we want to learn from
other humans so the other humans can be
people from within my organization like
can be internal my mentor from my
organization or they can be people or
who are external to the organization
like people who are trainers like sales
trainers or group facilitators or
mentors external mentors like a matching
fvp cells in one company with the cro
from another company or a coach and so
different types of experts providing
different types of growth so basically
growth space helps organizations to
manage one-on-one programs with external
experts when we could actually tailor
the right expert for each individual
growth path it can be in like small
group we call it team coaching it can be
workshops think of management training
sales training or it can be internal
mentoring so that's what growth space
does now how to understand what growth
do you need we basically
first understand the individual like the
I'm sorry first to understand the
organizational outcome so you want to
drive productivity or do you want to
reduce situation or do you want to build
your promotable base there are different
outcomes that you as a CEO will be
interested about and then we basically
derive individual plans for individuals
each one with their own outcomes that
they're trying to achieve and then we
will do everything in a screen setting
so usually it will be five sessions and
focused on one specific objective that
you're trying to achieve in a very short
period of time so if we will go let's
say you're a manager and you're very
centralized you're not delegating to
your people so your productivity is hurt
so you want in fight session to
basically delegate more so they will be
very very specific outcomes for the
individual manager and after five
sessions I want to see an actual
Improvement in the specific kpi
so is this a classification problem over
a sort of like a matching problem
between a desire plus personality to a
training program you have how do you how
do you even go about using technology to
do that successfully at skill because I
can I understand what if you know you
have some coach coming in and creating
some personalized program but obviously
you're you're a tech company how do you
how do you operate and create that
impact at scale here
sure so the first problem that you have
eventually what we do I think it's an
interesting space because up until covet
99 of the human human development has
happened face to face so you didn't
really have an access to a lot of
different experts you just had one
expert close to your office that they
will come in and kind of like train
everyone but it's not one size fits-on
that's a problem so I think the first
thing that technology enables us is to
really run it at scale so if now
tomorrow morning you will tell me or I
want to onboard 10 000 people to your
platform each one will get an individual
expert focusing and specializing what
they can what they actually need it's
almost an impossible task if you're a
company but with us you can basically do
that so with technology solve for a
scale that's number one and you're right
it's a lot around classification or we
call it taxonomy and data basically
because the the hardest thing in growth
is to find the right expert that fit the
right individual
there is a company called the world 50
in the US and and it's a very very wide
golf service basically finding the
perfect expert for like CEOs it cost you
like sixty thousand dollars or 100K so
it's super super expensive but they will
find the right CEO Mentor for every CEO
in the world so you're running a
shipping company that will find the
right Co in the shipping company with
that face similar challenges right but
you cannot do it at scale so basically
the way it's built in real space it's
built upon at taxonomy so we basically
mapped
um like three levels of taxonomy it's
like you have high level Focus areas
like management productivity sales and
then you have a skill sets and then you
have basically skills so we have over
400 different types of skills So
eventually each expert will be tagged on
the specific skills that they're good at
and they cannot do everything they need
to select for like from a very very
limited amount of skills and it will all
also tag their background where they
came from their industry So eventually
the data will help us to understand who
is good and what and then it's a rating
mechanism kind of like when you're
buying things on like a Booking.com for
example yeah how do you know if the
hotel is good if enough people rated
it's nine right that's how you look for
hotel more than Amazon when you buy
something so it's the same when you're
basically selecting the right experts
and especially if people that are
providing the ratings are similar to me
in nature right I think that's a big a
big step function that we've had in in
sort of personalized ratings where now
these platforms are offering these
ratings but based on individuals that
are similar to us whether it be in our
body physique if it's shopping for
clothes or whether it be you know our
personality if for for traveling based
on our previous
experiences how do you how do you
measure the effectiveness so how do you
close the loop of knowing whether the
program that you delivered or is or
assigned if was a successful one both to
the individual as well as the company
so in the individual level we basically
ask both the individual and the direct
manager about the outcome so in the
beginning of every process whether it's
one-on-one or a group uh we will define
an outcome that we want to achieve a
specific outcome tied to a specific
skill and so delegation you're now not
delegating anything I want you to start
delegating 20 of the work for example
and I want to see it happening within
two months
um so after two months I will come back
both to the participant the platform
we'll come back both to the participant
and the direct manager and we will ask
them whether the outcome has been
achieved now self-reporting is biased so
usually I will I can report yes I'm
delegating much more and but I'm not
really delegating but my manager usually
will have a better view on the actual
like change in my behavior so that's an
individual level in the organizational
level like in the company level we will
usually either connect to their business
kpis or organizational kpis so it can be
looking at like the engineering
throughput engineering velocity customer
churn sales conversions like really
business apis or it can be
organizational kpis like attrition again
promotions stuff like that or we can use
other tools like HR analytics or even
growth space platform enables you to
basically measure the actual impact in
the organizational level
okay that makes sense so I want to try
this a little bit back to you now I
guess who you know why you're doing what
you're doing so take me again through
sort of why do you care so much about
growth you care enough about it to run a
company doing it you know what what is
you know what is sort of your why here
and so first of all I will not take
credit for the idea I did have like a
lot of like I worked into space at
another I started in this space like
over 10 years ago but the idea came from
my co-founder one of my co-founders uh
Dan and when he just had a pain and the
company he worked for like a lot of
people were living and interpreter that
people were living because they didn't
feel the company is investing enough in
their world so we try to find a solution
but no solution out there really like
moved the needle So eventually he came
to me and he asked me like how do you
create effective development and he
called me because he knew I had some
experience in this space and I told him
nobody really know because no one really
works with data in this industry so
that's basically the story of grow space
uh personally I think for me the I first
of all I like to grow so like being a
founder and probably you can understand
it is as well it's one of the most like
you're growing every quarter in a crazy
way so it's really just being a startup
founder is a very uh growth a good
growth experience and specifically in
helping other people grow I think um
as people were looking for meaning and
we want to do cool stuff in the world
and eventually we're spending so many
hours in this thing called work so for
me I really like to think that the
energy I'm spending and a lot of people
working we're working with are spending
is eventually helping other people grow
how do you measure your own success
around what you do so how do you know
you've succeeded personally
so I can take it to like the
philosophical or I can take it to their
business so I think the business success
is business success eventually you know
you have SAS kpis you're managing to
fundraiser or growing the company
um
Etc but I think the more interesting
aspect of success is basically
um
like personal ones about the like how
equanimous you are through the process
it's a very stressful so how come like
whether you can uh inspire people
whether you can help as a manager to
grow your own people where people like I
think one of the best like metrics for a
manager is if they're subordinates were
like really successful after leaving the
company so I think for me it's uh
eventually the like personal growth that
I'm like I'm saying well I couldn't do
this specific thing like six months ago
but now I kind of Master that and you
have so many things to master so I think
it's very rewarding to just look back
and see like that all right guys can see
the enjoyment in your eyes so tell me a
little bit about where growth spaces now
we're in a January of 2023.
so uh growth spaces are growing which I
think um you know we're in times of
fairy sessions
and so I think this year will grow quite
a bit and it's like a wigro this year
from 40 people to 100
uh so
just repeat those two numbers
I'm sorry we grew this year from 40
people uh to 100 people so we grew
basically to an affix in 2012.
yes during and then so sort of the
recession as they call it
yes so for us we see that the again even
though there is a recession
companies are developing their managers
and their talent populations even more
than they used to so it's kind of like
some companies really showing their
budgets but especially a larger
companies or even investing more because
it's a lot around productivity and in
recession like let's say you're even
counting like a cutting head count and
you still want to make the existing
employees
um effective so we see and it grows even
in this time anything for a startup it's
basically moving from one stage like a
startup is a very interesting experience
because like your pains are different
like you always have pain uh you always
have like a suffering but like the pain
is different in every stage so now it's
basically scaling and building like a
larger organization basically building a
machine process system Etc
that mean that makes a lot of sense and
what's uh what's up ahead now for sort
of the bigger vision of growth space so
if you had to look
if you you know for the sort of the the
mile run here where we headed
so when we are the first company in the
Learning and Development space doing
what we do like really managing the
whole human to human development now
doing it right and doing it basically a
really really good
um it's kind of like it's a challenge of
building basically three different
companies because I mentioned that we're
doing internal mentoring we're doing
like external one-on-one a development
uh Sprints we're doing group so a lot of
different products basically in one
company so when you're asking me about
my vision it's just built the perfect
experience for human to human a growth
uh for companies and individuals and
just making it better and better so
enabling more skills more experts like
we have
um over 1600 experts currently and last
year we worked with people in 65
different countries so it means that you
need experts in more than 65 different
countries so this is just like a
complicated operation of delivering
different experiences in different parts
of the world in different skills so a
lot of metrics one on the other so if
you ask me what is our growth is just to
make it better and better and better and
this vision is big enough for everyone
thank you very much this was an awesome
episode thank you for joining me best of
luck with growth space I'll continue
cheering from the side and I really
appreciate your time and energy thank
you
thank you